[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui le trafic de drogue
ce commerce illégal mais lucratif ne
cesse de croître malgré les efforts
internationaux et se retrouve parfois au
centre de la lutte géopolitique alors
comment la guerre contre le trafic de
drogue impact tel les relations
internationales
le 26 mars 2020 l'administration trump
accuse le président vénézuélien nicolás
maduro d'être impliqué dans le trafic de
drogue aux états unis
prétextant la lutte antidrogue
washington lance alors une vaste
opération militaire dans les eaux des
caraïbes à proximité des côtes du
venezuela caracas de son côté rejette
fermement les accusations américaines
selon l'onu c'est la colombie qui serait
responsable de l'inondation des
stupéfiants sur le marché américain
et cela malgré vingt ans de lutte anti
drogue sous l'égide de washington
une lutte qui montre ses limites aussi
en afghanistan où malgré les opérations
américaines la situation reste très
compliquée à l'échelle mondiale la
guerre contre le trafic ne mène pas non
plus aux résultats escomptés
parmi les causes la corruption et les
liens étroits des pouvoirs locaux avec
les cartels
nombreux sont les cas où la population
dépend fortement des revenus du trafic
de drogue
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici les
dernières données sur la consommation
est la vente de drogue publié par l'onu
c'est le blitz à l'échelle mondiale 271
millions de personnes on consommait de
la drogue en 2017 soit une hausse de 30%
depuis 2009 le taux de mortalité est
tout aussi alarmant quelques 185 mille
personnes sont décédées des suites de la
consommation de drogues de toutes sortes
pendant l'année 2010 est la drogue la
plus répandue au monde dresse le
cannabis 188 millions de personnes en
ont consommé en 2017
viennent ensuite les opioïdes opium
morphine et l'héroïne avec 58 millions
d'usagers
enfin la troisième drogue la plus
populaire est la cocaïne elle est
consommée par 18 millions de personnes
dans le monde
le plus grand nombre de consommateurs de
drogues se trouvent en amérique du nord
ce fléau concernerait ici environ 74
millions de personnes l'asie du sud
vient juste après plus grand marché de
puits d'eau monde
cette région compte 51 millions
d'usagers de substances illicites
l'autre consommateurs importants et
l'europe occidentale et centrale
ici plus de 36 millions de personnes
prennent des substances psychotropes
nouvelle offensive diplomatique
américaine contre le venezuela
donald trump accuse le président du pays
nicolás maduro d'être impliqué dans le
trafic de drogue aux états unis
une opération militaire est même lancé à
proximité des côtes du venezuela
pourtant selon l'onu ce n'est pas se
piquer le plus grand producteur de
drogues sur le continent mais la
colombie alliés traditionnels américains
plus de 90% de tous les stupéfiants qui
entrent aux états unis proviendrait de
la colombie et cela malgré l'aide
financière et militaire que les états
unis lui prête pour combattre ce fléau
depuis une vingtaine d'années pourtant
le résultat s'avère quasi nulle le
trafic continue à prospérer tout comme
au mexique d'ailleurs qui bénéficie
aussi du soutien américain en
afghanistan
la production d'opium a doublé pendant
la présence américaine
pourtant des tendances négatives se
dessine dans toutes les régions du monde
l'offre et la demande de substances
psychoactives sont globalement en hausse
la situation sème l'inquiétude à l'onu
qui appelle un changement d'approché
dans la lutte contre le trafic de drogue
alors comment ce marché illicite se
développe-t-il et pourquoi prospère t-il
malgré tant d'efforts verra-t-on un jour
le démantèlement des réseaux mondiaux
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons xavier raufer criminologue
directeur d'études au pôle sécurité
défense du cnam
monsieur robert bonjour bonjour tout
d'abord pourquoi selon vous la
consommation de drogue dans le monde ne
cesse-t-elle pas d'augmenter aujourd'hui
malgré une lutte incessante contre ce
fléau
alors il y a naturellement à une
question aussi complexe
il n'y a pas une seule réponse mais on
peut simplement remarquer que
l'éclatement de la société le fait que
dans beaucoup de sociétés notamment
européennes je parle de ce que je
connais le mieux de la société
européenne que dans ses sociétés
on est à l'ère de ce que longtemps déjà
à sociologue américain avait appelé la
foule solitaire
quand les gens sont solitaires quand
plus rien ne les retient de la famille
des groupes humains etc
ils ont tendance à sombrer dans une
sorte de tristesse parfois de désespoir
et à ce moment là dans un premier temps
avant naturellement que ça ne les tue
trop souvent la drogue peut être une
consolation voilà je dirais qu'il ya
naturellement pourquoi un individu
consomment des stupéfiants
il ya cinquante réponse à ça mais la
plus importante la plus massive c'est
l'échec des sociétés dites libérales
avancé à avoir constitué des des
solidarités dans lesquelles la
consommation de drogue ne deviendrait
plus quelque chose de désirable donc
c'est surtout selon vous un changement
sociétal et pourquoi donc la lutte
incessante nos portes elle pas ses
fruits alors c'est non seulement une pas
porter des fruits mais c'est un échec
absolu
considéré que depuis maintenant un demi
siècle
jamais la livraison de cocaïne en europe
n'a été même ralenti on a naturellement
de ça des preuves formelles
la drogue est une marchandise illicite
la cocaïne est une marchandise illicite
mais c'est une marchandise quand même
donc il y à la loi de l'offre et de la
demande
et quand bien entendu vous avez une
saisie énorme de drogue et de cocaïne
les prix à la consommation augmente
chaque jour dans tous les pays d'europe
des policiers en civil vont acheter des
doses de drogue auprès des dealers
auprès des trafiquants et donc ils
connaissent le prix de la drogue au jour
le jour si il y à une tendance qui se
dessine au cours des trois ou quatre
dernières décennies c'est que le prix
des stupéfiants notamment les
stupéfiants les plus graves les plus
tragiques pour la santé que son
l'héroïne et la cocaïne par exemple ces
prix baissent ce qui coûtait il y a
encore une dizaine d'années 60 à 80
euros le demi gramme de cocaïne n'en
coûte plus aujourd'hui à paris dans la
rue que par exemple 40 euros le demi
gramme donc vous avez des prix qui
baissent et donc ça signifie que les
livraisons s'effectuent toujours de
manière parfaitement aisée pour les
trafiquants merci beaucoup monsieur
raufer nous allons poursuivre notre
analyse tout de suite mais nous
retrouverons en fin d'émission pour plus
de détails sur la question merci
beaucoup
l'administration trump accentue la
pression sur le venezuela le 26 mars le
ministère de la justice américain accuse
le président vénézuélien nicolás maduro
et plusieurs membres de son entourage
d'être à la tête d'un cartel est d'avoir
organisé le trafic de drogue aux états
unis
comme supposé maduro et les autres
accusés avaient expressément l'intention
d'y
non dès les états unis de cocaïne afin
de nuire à la santé et au bien-être de
notre nation prétextant la défense des
intérêts nationaux donald trump annonce
le 1er avril une importante opération
militaire dans les eaux des caraïbes
navires de guerre avions de surveillance
et forces spéciales terrestres
c'est le plus grand déploiement
militaire américain dans les caraïbes
depuis les années 1990 selon le
ministère américain de la défense
l'opération est soutenue par 22 pays
tous situés autour du bassin des
caraïbes
de son côté caracas qu'est les filles
cette opération de provocation organisée
à des fins politiques
quant aux accusations de trafic de
drogue le venezuela refuse de les
prendre au sérieux évoquant la lutte
impitoyable que le pays mène contre ce
fléau
des efforts qui ont d'ailleurs été
saluée par le nu selon le dernier
rapport de l'organe international de
contrôle des stupéfiants rien qu'en 2018
les autorités vénézuéliennes ont saisi
30 5,5 tonnes de cocaïne
c'est la deuxième plus grosse quantité
intercepté au monde à cela s'ajoute
également plus de sept tonnes de
cannabis confisquée par la police
nationale
washington continue à pointer le
venezuela du doigt mais selon l'onu le
principal producteur de drogue en
amérique du sud se trouve ailleurs et
c'est bien l'allié traditionnel
américain
la colombie selon les dernières
estimations de la maison blanche rien
qu'en 2019 les cartels colombiens ont
produit neuf cent cinquante et une tonne
de cocaïne soit trois fois plus qu'il ya
cinq ans la superficie des cultures de
coca y est c'est en à pas de géant elle
passe de 48 mille hectares en 2013 à 212
mille hectares en 2019 et aujourd'hui la
colombie s'affirme aussi comme un
producteur d'héroïne la culture illégale
du pavot à opium dépasse aujourd'hui 280
hectares avec une production qui s'élève
à plusieurs tonnes et tout cela malgré
une aide américaine contre le trafic qui
se poursuit depuis une vingtaine
d'années tout commence en 2000 par le
plan colombie fruit de longues
négociations entre bogota et washington
un vertu de cet accord le gouvernement
américain a fourni
milliards de dollars à la colombie
durant les quinze premières années
côté militaire environ 1600 soldats
américains participent régulièrement à
des opérations conjointes avec les
forces colombiennes
il y a eu quand même une avancée majeure
grâce à une pression constante et au
déploiement des moyens colossaux les
farc ont été contraints de déposer les
armes
cependant ce vide a été vite comblé par
de nouveaux groupes paramilitaires liée
principalement aux cartels mexicains
aujourd'hui ces liens restent toujours
étroits et cela malgré les opérations
anti drogue en colombie et la guerre
contre les cartels au mexique
pourtant si bogota bénéficier d'une aide
militaire américaine
mexico se contente d'un soutien
financier et technologique de washington
des dizaines d'avions de surveillance
plusieurs hélicoptères de nouveaux
systèmes de surveillance des frontières
tout cet équipement accompagné de
centaines de millions de dollars et
fournit au gouvernement mexicain dans le
cadre de l'initiative mérida signé en
2008 cet accord bilatéral vise à arrêter
le trafic de drogue aux états unis
malgré certaines avancées dans la lutte
contre les principaux cartels le
problème est toujours loin d'être
éradiquée selon le dernier rapport de
l'agencé américaine de lutte contre la
drogue
le mexique reste le principal
fournisseur d'héroïne
aux etats unis les routes les plus
lucratives du trafic sont contrôlés par
les plus grands cartels ceux de sinaloa
du golf de tijuana deux états de juarez
et celui des tant pis a eu 6 il
représente des milliards de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires et produisent
plusieurs centaines de tonnes de drogue
par an par ailleurs le taux de
criminalité ne cesse de monter pour la
seule année 2010 9 les autorités
mexicaines ont enregistré 35 1588
homicide
un niveau de violence historique début
novembre 2019 trois familles américaines
sont violemment attaqué par un des
cartels de la région les trois mères de
famille sont mortes
ainsi que six de leurs enfants un
véritable massacre qui provoque la
colère de la maison blanche
en réaction donald trump se dit prêt à
apporter un soutien militaire au mexique
pour lutter contre les cartels une
proposition que la diplomatie mexicaine
ge est catégoriquement le mexique
n'admettra jamais la moindre action
entraînant une violation de sa
souveraineté nationale
nous agirons avec fermeté cette fermeté
du mexique pourrait s'expliquer par un
autre exemple d'intervention militaire
américaine qui a atteint quelques
objectifs mais pense qui concerne la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue c'est
le cas de l'afghanistan
depuis 2001 les etats-unis y mène des
opérations à la fois contre les taliban
et contre le trafic d'opium 19 ans plus
tard les talibans sont toujours actifs
sur la plupart du territoire afghan
alors que le trafic de drogue prospère
l'afghanistan produit environ 90% de
l'opium mondial
en moins de vingt ans de présence
américaine la production d'opium a
doublé passant de 3000 tonnes en 2000 à
6700 tonnes en 2019 pareil pour la
culture du pavot à opium et les deux
cent soixante mille hectares aujourd'hui
soit deux fois de plus qu'en 2000 alors
quels sont les défis qui freine la lutte
anti drogue à l'échelle mondiale qui
sont les principaux producteurs et
consommateurs de stupéfiants
comment la guerre contre ce fléau at
elle évolué au fil des années la réponse
après la pause
[Musique]
depuis des décennies les gouvernements
du monde entier combattre le trafic de
drogue
bien sûr le nu et joue aussi un rôle
important pourtant les modes
d'acheminement de production et de vente
de stupéfiants deviennent aussi de plus
en plus élaborées quand ce n'est pas le
meurtre c'est la corruption qui permet
aux cartels de lever la plupart des
obstacles au trafic
longtemps considérés comme produits aux
vertus médicinales ou spirituelle et
drogue à usage récréatif se répandent au
sein de la population générale
au 19ème siècle les empires coloniaux
tels que la grande-bretagne la france ou
les pays-bas en pause le commerce
lucratif de l'opium alors colonie zazie
atik le volume de production ne cesse de
croître et une épidémie document
engouffre d'abord l'asie ensuite les
métropoles craignons que le problème de
dépendance ne prenne de l'ampleur au
niveau mondial les etats-unis convoque
en 1909 une conférence internationale à
shanghai qui débouche trois ans plus
tard sur la signature de la convention
internationale de l'opium utilisation de
ce psychotropes est restreinte à des
fins médicinales et la contrebande est
interdite saignée par une dizaine de
pays cette convention n'est pas
contraignante mais permet quand même de
maîtriser la production et la
consommation de l'opium
cependant de nouveaux dérivés tels que
la morphine et l'héroïne se répandent
parallèlement ainsi que la cocaïne
initialement légaux tous sont considérés
comme des remèdes miracles avant que
leur potentiel addictif ne soient mis au
jour plusieurs pays tentent de mettre en
place des réglementations plus strictes
entre 1912 et 1953 neuf conventions
internationales ont été adoptés mais
elles ont des effets limités après de
longues négociations les nations unies
adopte la convention unique sur les
stupéfiants en 1961 elle interdit hors
fins médicales le commerce et la
production des opioïdes naturels et
synthétiques de la cocaïne et du
cannabis
dès lors la convention devient un pilier
de la politique mondiale de lutte contre
les drogues au cours des années 60 la
plupart des états du monde intègre
progressivement ces clauses dans leur
législation
pourtant c'est aussi la période quand
les drogues récréatives attire de plus
en plus cela s'explique par les
changements sociaux et culturels tels
que la libération sexuelle et la période
dite hippie qui s'opèrent en amérique du
nord et en europe
l'expansion est aggravée par des drogues
de synthèse relativement nouvelles comme
les amphétamines ou le lsd qui ne sont
pas mentionnés dans le traité de 1961 la
nouvelle convention des nations unies de
1971 ajoute alors ces drogues à sa liste
de stupéfiants cependant ni cette
convention ni celle de 1961 oblige les
états incriminés ni à réprimer usage de
stupéfiants les états unis déclare alors
le 17 juillet 1971 la guerre contre la
drogue
il prenait alors une tolérance zéro
multipliant les arrestations et
condamnant les consommateurs à de
lourdes peines de prison
pourtant durant les années 80 le trafic
de drogue continue d'augmenter les
cartels opérant depuis l'amérique du sud
le bassin méditerranéen et l'asie du
sud-est fleurissent certains échappent
au contrôle des états faibles d'autres
vont jusqu'à collaborer directement avec
les gouvernements les nations unies sert
donc à nouveau les vices et signe en
décembre 1988 la convention contre le
trafic illicite de stupéfiants et de
substances psychotropes contraignant
pour la première fois les états à
poursuivre pénalement les consommateurs
et les producteurs de drogues en 1998
l'onu adopte le slogan un monde sans
drogue nous pouvons y arriver
les états s'engagent à réduire voire
éliminer la production de toutes les
drogues illicites dans le monde d'ici
dix ans des objectifs très ambitieux
mais dépourvue de nouvelle mesure
concrète
en effet la consommation de drogue dans
le monde augmente c'est tout
particulièrement le cas pour la cocaïne
son nombre de consommateurs passent de
14 millions 998 à 18,8 millions en 2014
face au problème de santé publique à
savoir une augmentation des décès liés
aux overdoses et au vih certains pays
souhaitent adopter dès les années 2000
une approche différente en 2001 le
portugal est le premier pays a
dépénalisé la possession de toutes les
drogues à usage personnel
de nombreux pays préfèrent alors
dépénaliser une seule drogue
le cannabis drogue la plus consommée au
monde depuis 1976 au total plus d'une
dizaine l'ont déjà fait alors que de
nombreux pays se détournent de la dope
une prohibitionniste l'onu recommande en
2016 de nouvelles pratiques focaliser
sur la prévention
pourtant démanteler les réseaux
existants restent essentielles pour
endiguer le narcotrafic et cet objectif
est loin d'être atteint en 2010 est le
commerce illégal de la drogue a généré
dans le monde environ 500 milliards de
dollars
résistante est capable de s'adapter à un
clin d'oeil et l'industrie des
stupéfiants se porte aujourd'hui mieux
que jamais les réseaux du narcotrafic
couvre aujourd'hui toute la planète et
ne cesse d'élargir leur portée l'exemple
de la cocaïne et le plus parlant la
production de ce stimulant est
concentrée dans trois pays la colombie
le pérou et la bolivie leur climat
permet à la plante de coca extrêmement
exigeante de pousser dans des conditions
optimales à partir de ces trois pays la
cocaïne est acheminé vers les principaux
clients par des bandes colombienne leurs
partenaires criminelle en argentine au
brésil où des cartels mexicains
l'ultra puissant d'abord via le mexique
elle arrive en amérique du nord est de
loin la plus grande consommatrice du
monde
le deuxième marché le plus important l
europe la drogue était acheminée par
l'atlantique depuis le venezuela le
brésil ou l'argentine
ces trajets sont bien connus et ne cesse
d'évoluer
la voie terrestre par l'amérique
centrale a remplacé la voix caribéenne
trop bien surveillé et sur la direction
européenne l'afrique de l'ouest devient
le rôle est de plus en plus utilisé les
deux tiers de la cocaïne destinée à
l'union européenne y transitent
avant de suivre vers le sahel puis vers
le nord en plus de nouvelles routes la
coke conquièrent de nouveaux marchés
elle monte en popularité en asie au
moyen-orient et même en océanie où elles
arrivent via l'océan pacifique pour des
centaines de milliers de familles
paysannes la cocaïne est la principale
source de revenus et parfois même la
seule ils sont donc prêts à courir tous
les dangers pour gagner leur pain une
situation qui rappelle tristement
l'afghanistan centre mondial de culture
du pavot à opium
selon le lieu 90% de tous l'opium de la
planète viendrait de cette région sa
culture est surtout associé aux talibans
il en tire la plupart de leurs revenus
et l'encouragent dans les territoires
qu'ils contrôlent pour les fermiers
locaux elle est aussi le meilleur moyen
de survivre
c'est donc en afghanistan que naissent
les principales voies d'acheminement de
l'héroïne vers le reste du monde par
l'asie centrale l'héroïne afghane est
acheminé vers la russie une partie
continue son chemin et arrive en europe
c'est la route du nord la route du sud
elle traverse l'asie du sud et du
sud-est pour atteindre la chine
l'australie et l'amérique du nord
finalement la route dite des balkans via
l'iran la turquie et l'europe orientale
est traditionnellement la plus utilisée
pour atteindre l'union européenne
cependant à cause de la guerre en syrie
et la crise des réfugiés ankara et
bruxelles surveille de mieux en mieux
leurs frontières
le trafic se voit donc obligé de prendre
d'autres chemins
une nouvelle route fait alors son
apparition dans l'hémisphère sud
une fois tant la côte pakistanaise
l'héroïne passe par l'océan indien et
sous des verts sur l'afrique de l'est
puis remonte vers la méditerranée
les malversations les trafics
d'influencé les détournements et les
manoeuvres politiques sont autant de
raisons de l'échec global face au
commerce des stupéfiants en afrique
la guinée-bissau est parfois considérée
par certains analystes comme un
prototype de narco état
depuis les années 2000 les liens entre
bissao et les trafiquants sud-américains
sont un des milk
présidentielle de 2005 assassinat du
président joao bernardo vieira en 2009
coup d'état en 2012
leurs traces sont partout en 2016 la
mayral bissao guinéen na tchuto est
condamné par une cour américaine pour
trafic de drogue est généralisée en
afrique
cette collusion n'épargne pas d'autres
continents en 2017
la sphère françois thiery éclate en
france l'ancien patron de la lutte
antidrogue et mise en examen pour
complicité de narcotrafic
deux nouveaux cas au plus haut niveau ne
cessent de surgir quatre coins du monde
en albanie en algérie aux philippines au
honduras ou au guatemala
la dernière affaire emblématique
concerne le mexique fin 2010 9
l'architecte de sa fameuse guerre contre
la drogue et narrow garcia luna est
arrêté aux états unis pour complicité
avec le sinistre cartel des chapeaux le
sinaloa drogue dissimulés dans de la
nourriture paquet à avaler aux attachés
des animaux les cartes elles tentent à
tout prix de sécuriser leurs cargaisons
cependant le transport reste l'étape la
plus dangereuse du trafic
l'herbe de cannabis les amphétamines et
d'autres drogues de synthèse toutes ces
substances sont discrètement dissimuler
des saisies record sont tout de même
enregistrer chaque année pourtant
l'industrie n'en est pas à perturber la
proche choisi il ya plus de cent ans
montre hôtels des signes d'épuisement
selon l'onu il est temps de chercher de
nouvelles stratégies de lutte les pays
qui ont misé sur cette approche ne sont
pas plus débarrasser de la drogue
au contraire aujourd'hui la variété et
la quantité de drogue produite et
consommée sont plus élevées que jamais
quand une politique n'arrive de toute
évidence pas atteindre ces objectifs il
faut en changer la narco économie
est-elle trop ancré dans le commerce
mondial pourrait être éradiquée pour
examiner les stratégies et les
divergences nous allons revenir vers
xavier raufer criminologue directeur
d'études au pôle sécurité défense du
cnam
monsieur raufer parlant maintenant côté
géopolitique et de la guerre contre la
drogue
les etats unis accusent le venezuela
d'être un arc aux états ont-ils raison
selon vous où en fait les situations ou
chez leurs alliés comme la colombie ou
le honduras est bien pire
alors les états unis
pays que je connais bien pays dans
lequel j'ai été enseigné pendant des
années j'ai donné des cours j'ai
participé des dizaines de conférences je
connais bien d'innombrables officiel
américain a chargé des affaires de
sécurité en fond de tableau qu'il faut
toujours revenir sur les fondamentaux
parce que quand on oublie les
fondamentaux après ça on a une vision
partielle des choses
les etats-unis en tant que nation se
considèrent mais très profondément comme
un modèle pour l'ensemble de l'humanité
de cetti en 2000 l'espèce de ville qui
brille dans lé sommet de la colline au
sommet de la montagne et donc de ce fait
depuis l'origine depuis qu'ils ont été
fondés ils ont comment dire toujours
tendance à donner des leçons et à penser
que quand tu te crois qu'un pays est
gentil le pays en question lait et qu'il
est méchant et bien il est méchant et il
nous donne à l'europe à la france des
leçons sur le racisme et l'esclavagé
songez que c'est seulement en 1948 en
tant qu'être humain j'étais déjà menées
depuis deux ans qu'on a aboli la
discrimination raciale dans l'armée
américaine c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas se
mêlant on a pu commencer à mélanger les
êtres humains mais non pas les séparer
en fonction de leur couleur de peau
donc les états unis sont comme ça alors
quand ils ont des gens qu'ils
considèrent comme gentil c'est à dire
par exemple ceux dans lesquels leurs
intérêts sont bien défendus comme la
colombie ou qu'il n'insiste pas trop et
quand ils considèrent des pays comme
étant hostiles comme ayant un régime que
je considère comme mauvais ils les à
table vous voyez par exemple dans le cas
de la colombie je vais vous donner un
exemple précis
les etats-unis ont prétendu vouloir
comment dire éradiquer la fabrication la
culture de la coca en colombie
mais quand vous regardez les choses de
près vous vous apercevez que plutôt que
de l'éradiquer complètement
ils ont repoussé la culture de la coca
dans les zones les plus proches du
bassin amazonien
ce qui fait que une fois que vous êtes
dans le bassin amazonien la façon la
plus simple d'exporter la cocaïne c'est
par les fleuves donc par le brésil donc
en face par l'afrique et après ça vers
l'europe et prétendant lutter contre la
production de cocaïne qui sont en
réalité écarté cette production la de la
direction des etats-unis c'est-à-dire
amérique latine amérique centrale
mexique etats unis et ils l'ont envoyé
vers l'europe
donc vous voyez contre les grandes
déclarations théorique et puis ce qu' il
est fait en réalité il y as parfois il
ya une distance et il faut regarder tout
ça de près donc même si les états unis
continuent à soutenir financièrement les
pays de l'amérique latine pour lutter
contre la drogue vous pensez que c'est
une en soutien c'est une lutte sans fin
alors ça va être décalé à chaque fois
vers d'autres pays et puis ça ne portera
jamais ses fruits il est très difficile
qu'ils y arrivent regarder ce qui se
passe avec le mexique par exemple
mexique est un état d'amérique du nord
il les paie xi qu'un tiennent beaucoup à
cette qualification là mais qui est un
pays latin parlant naturellement
l'espagnol ce pays
de plus les états unis aident le mexique
et plus la quantité d'assassinât et
d'homicides qui s'y connaît est énorme
cette année en 2020 on va encore battre
le record de 2010 9 qui était déjà
épouvantable depuis le début de la
guerre à la drogue au mexique
il y a eu plus de 200000 morts et plus
de 40000 disparition à un moment donné
quand la guerre était encore active en
irak et qu'elle était encore active elle
l'est toujours mais moins en afghanistan
on estimait que le nombre de morts au
nord du mexique était plus important que
celui qu'il est qu on pouvait constater
en irak et en afghanistan pays en proie
à des guerres civiles importantes
merci beaucoup monsieur refaire je
rappelle et xavier raufer était avec
nous aujourd'hui criminologue directeur
d'études au pôle sécurité défense du
cnam
merci encore
est reparti là n'est pas encore terminée
la semaine prochaine une nouvelle partie
vous attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]